[Applause]
it was just two and a half weeks ago
that the statues of great americans
passed
looked on as a pro-trump mob desecrated
the u.s
capitol now they watch as house
impeachment managers march past
to the senate bearing papers that
charged
former president trump with inciting an
insurrection
donald john trump engaged in high crimes
and misdemeanors
by inciting violence against the
government of the united
states the accusation relates to the
events of january
6 when trump gave a speech to supporters
telling them to march to the capitol
and fight like hell because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show
strength the rioters broke into the
legislative chambers
in a failed effort to stop congress from
certifying joe biden's election win
five people died as a result president
trump gravely endangered the security
of the united states and its
institutions of government
he threatened the integrity of the
democratic system
interfered with the peaceful transition
of power
and imperiled a co-equal branch of
government if these proceedings look
familiar
it's because they're a repeat of events
from a year ago when trump was impeached
the first time
he's now the only u.s president who's
been impeached twice
and the only one to be tried after
leaving office
some republicans have argued that should
make this impeachment illegal
but constitutional experts say otherwise
from constitutional structure and from
our history
there is no reason to suppose that he
cannot now be
tried and convicted on the article of
impeachment that was voted while he was
still president
trump was acquitted in his first
impeachment when only
one senate republican voted against him
conviction this time around would
require the votes of
17 republican senators
then and only then could a simple
majority in the senate
vote to bar trump from holding future
public office
polls show a slim majority of americans
do want trump to suffer that consequence
[Applause]
but as the january 6th riot fades
further into memory
more republicans appear to be leaning
away from conviction
the legal teams now have two weeks to
prepare before the trial begins
in mid-february heidi joe castro al
jazeera washington